Looks like the Batman may have a whole lot
of villainous trouble to deal with when the
Dark Knight returns.
A fresh report from We Got This Covered has
suggested that Robert Pattinson's version
of the Caped Crusader will face no fewer than
six villains in his first solo outing: the
Penguin, the Riddler, Catwoman, Two-Face,
Firefly, and the Mad Hatter.
In its coverage of The Batman, the outlet
has previously reported that The Riddler,
the Penguin, Catwoman, Two-Face, Scarecrow
and Bane have all been under consideration
for a part in the movie's story, with potentially
all six of them showing up at the same time.
According to the more recent report, however,
those last two have been subbed out in favor
of some slightly more obscure characters.
Before we go on, though, let's note that a
lot can change behind the scenes during the
development of a movie - especially this particular
movie.
Nothing is certain 'til it's certain - and
any rumors swirling around this project ought
to be taken with a bunch of grains of you-know-what.
"Could you pass the salt?"
Of the two new additions to the movie's potential
rogues' gallery, Firefly seems like the best
fit for the noir-styled narrative that writer/director
Matt Reeves reportedly has in mind for the
film.
The character first appeared way back in 1952,
in Detective Comics #184.
An expert in pyrotechnics who plied his trade
in the motion picture industry, Garfield Lynns
found himself mired in poverty when work dried
up.
Like so many of Gotham's destitute citizens,
he soon turned to a life of crime - drawing
the attention of Batman and Robin, who captured
him during a robbery attempt.
In later stories, Lynns enacted his revenge
by lashing out with acts of arson - and soon
took quite a liking to it.
Always on the hunt for bigger and bigger targets,
he eventually set fire to a chemical factory
and succumbed to the flames himself.
He survived the blaze but was left covered
in severe burns.
Inexplicably, Lynns continued on with his
new line of work, making himself a special
fire-resistant suit and an array of new weapons
before taking on the guise of the supervillain
Firefly.
According to We Got This Covered's report,
an early production document indicates that
Lynn's backstory will possibly be revised
to make him a man in his twenties who grew
up orphaned before embarking on a fiery rampage
against the privileged people of Gotham, which
could make for an interesting parallel with
Batman's own backstory.
The Mad Hatter's history stretches even further
back in DC lore, all the way to his first
appearance in 1948's Batman #49.
First portrayed as a common criminal with
an unusual affinity for his namesake, Jervis
Tetch has since been shown to possess a high
degree of skill in electrical engineering,
which he uses to produce his signature devices:
mind-controlling hats.
As for the other bad guys said to be on tap
for The Batman, any of them could be solid
choices, just so long as they're done properly.
The Penguin and the Riddler are two iconic
villains whose previous big-screen appearances
tended toward the garish and comedic, and
while Two-Face was certainly done justice
by Aaron Eckhart's performance in The Dark
Knight, many fans felt that the character
was given too little screen time.
As for Catwoman - well, whoever ends up taking
that role has some mighty boots to fill.
However it all shakes out, it's important
to remember that none of this is confirmed,
and these characters could easily be swapped
out or cut altogether before The Batman's
final shooting script is in place.
After all, front-loading a film with six villains
seems mightily ambitious, and it's not like
superhero movies haven't struggled to juggle
bad guys in the past.
"Where do all these guys come from?"
Whatever course Reeves does choose to take,
fans will just have to have faith in his talent
- and hope that the director can deliver both
the Batman we need… and the Batman we deserve.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.